15h01 hélicoptères dans le ciel creusois
est venu du ciel
devinez qui les frères bogdanoff en
personne sans combinaison essence ou
coup à la rencontre d'un illustre
terriens nac est d'initier un jean
guitton dans sa propriété de champagne
en creuse
explication de cette rencontre
littéraire et scientifique par les
visiteurs eux-mêmes
nous sommes venus lui annoncer une très
très grande nouvelle c'était important
de toujours en soyons là aujourd'hui
la grande nouvelle est que pour la
première fois il vient de dépasser
valéry giscard d'estaing dans le domaine
et s'est toujours dit que ça s'est passé
le domaine des ventes du livre que nous
avons fait en commun qui s'appelle donc
dieu et la science
et ce livre dieu et la science qui vient
d'être publié a dépassé 100 mille
exemplaires en quatre semaines et vient
donc de se positionner en numéro 1 des
ventes sur le plan national ces kits
extraordinaire alors c'est un événement
tellement important sur le plan national
sur le plan des idées et sur le plan de
la littérature sur le plan de la
philosophie que je crois que sur le plan
local sévérité que nous fassions à des
taux et des tours qui comptera autant
pour les frères bogdanoff que pour notre
caméra autorisé à saisir ce moment rare
et privilégié la visite guidée par jean
guitton humaine de sa maison creusoise
remplie de souvenirs
à commencer par les souvenirs d'enfance
souvenir encore celui de son épouse
à travers cet émouvant portrait pour
terminer la visite de la chapelle le
lieu symbole qui nous ramène à la raison
même de cette visite
l'ouvragé de jean guitton et les frères
bogdanoff dieu et la science
histoire d'une rencontre
pendant quatre ans j'ai vu les faire
tous les mois pour réfléchir sur ce
problème la vie au bout de quatre ans où
nous avions écrit ensemble un livre de
500 pages j'ai réduit avec l'une des
avantages en livre de 50 pages que vous
avez dans les mains de telle sorte que
ce livre ont pu se lire en une nuit
quand la peur des gens commencent à 10
heures du soir à 2 heures du matin il
l'a fait nice alors c'est un tout petit
lille mais qui contient un élixir enfin
des charges assez il vérité